This video is brought to you by surf shark, VPN
What's up,
why's crack Jared here to talk about one of the dumber conspiracy theories we've
ever come across.
The idea that 5g has caused the global pandemic known as COVID-19.
Um, all these desperate times are full of snake oil salesman.
This one perhaps takes the cake meet Thomas Cowan Thomas'
video,
claiming that 5g causes COVID-19 had over half a million views on YouTube before
being taken down. And that idea with the help of celebrities like Woody,
Harrelson is gaining traction in the UK.
People have torched several 5g towers for its alleged role in the pandemic.
The UK has reported around 50 fires,
targeting towers and other 5g equipment. Okay.
Of course, this is all bonkers and we'll get to that,
but we nonetheless wanted to dive deep into what exactly these people are saying
and why,
because the line between science and non-science is not as easy to discern as
one might think. So how can we tell the difference?
Let's find out welcome to this wisecrack edition on the anatomy of
pseudoscience, but before we get into it,
I want to give a shout out to this week's sponsor surf shark VPN.
A VPN is a virtual private network,
a tool that can be used to connect to the internet securely.
When you connect to the internet with a VPN,
your IP address and other valuable data are encrypted protecting you against
hackers.
This means you can safely use your banking info without fear of a leaked pin
surf shark goes above and beyond your typical VPN by offering extra services
like kill switch,
which disables your internet connection when your VPN stops working.
So you're always protected.
They also offer an ad and cookie blockers that sites can't collect data or
target you with ads.
The best part about surf shark is that you only need one subscription to connect
to an unlimited amount of devices. You can connect on your computer phone, iPad,
or even your gaming console,
protect yourself online and download surf shark VPN today.
Click the link in the description and use the promo code wisecrack to get 85%
off your subscription, plus three months free. And now back to the show,
let's get back to Thomas. His pitch is simple. When our cells get sick,
they excrete toxins and 5g is poisoning.
Those cells causing them to poop out his words.
The body is pooping out poisons.
It's obviously not good to eat other people's Pope.
Sins that make us sick with a little thing called COVID-19.
In his many YouTube videos, he makes a series of incredible claims.
They include viruses don't cause diseases.
The Spanish flu that killed tens of millions was caused by the electrification
of the earth and radio waves because we're electrical beings.
Other major outbreaks in the last century were caused by said electrification.
Also, he's an anti-vaxxer obviously the most outlandish part about this is how
technology has caused all these infectious diseases,
especially given the many fun and exciting infectious diseases that were among
the leading causes of death, pre electricity, like smallpox, bubonic plague,
or the measles to be fair.
Proving diseases existed before radio doesn't prove radios can't make us sick,
but Cowen's entire worldview seems to be natural equals good.
Like when he talks about all the pure water we used to drink,
there was no toxic stuff dissolved in the water and conveniently forgets.
The thousands of years,
people would drop dead of drinking water teaming with pathogens from your
upstream neighbors, you might be asking, how do people fall for this?
You might respond. They're stupid. But I think this excuse is lazy.
Plenty of smart and thoughtful people fall for pseudo-scientific nonsense.
And you probably will.
At some point in your life do the same suit of science often looks like real
science experts will be trotted out MDs PhDs from real
universities they'll even have evidence and studies.
But one of the most interesting things about pseudoscience is the use and abuse
of this evidence and the basic problem of context.
So let's talk about context.
There's one pretty illustrative example from Netflix's goop series.
In one episode and energy healer insists that his 100% not scientifically backed
energy healing process of waving his hands over your body really does work by
using a rock solid piece of evidence. The double slit experiment.
One foundational study is called the double slit experiment proved in Paraguay
without a shadow of a doubt that our consciousness actually shifts or
alters in some way, shape or form physical reality.
You might remember this experiment mentioned in high school or college physics,
but the takeaway is this light can act like a particle or wave,
but if observed it will collapse into its particle state that this proves our
mind can affect the material world is well not completely bogus,
but so vague that it could be construed to mean anything.
Our consciousness affects physical reality all the time as it instructs my Palm
to cover my face in complete disbelief that Netflix aired the show.
She threw up from 3:00 AM to 4:00 AM.
But sadness aside, such a claim relies on a few things.
One a misunderstanding of the context of the experiment light collapses into a
single stage because it has to interact with the measuring tool, observing it,
not because our consciousness willed it to be so to a large interpretive
leap that goes above and beyond the extremely limited hypothesis that the
experiment is testing Q the science explaining text on screen and the use of the
word implies.
Let's just say you could we'll light to be a particle or wave by thinking it
does an experiment that proves this mean you can make weird puppet gestures to
cure people's ailments. No,
the basic problem is this pseudoscience often preys on the fact that victims are
educated. For instance,
anti-vaxxers tend to be more educated than their well vaccinated peers.
We all can't be quantum theory, experts or immunologists.
So instead they give us evidence that often conforms to our basic understanding
of science.
So when energy Healy man explains the energy that runs through our muscles,
it seems to vaguely sound like our understanding of.
Of anatomy. You have energy,
that's bound up in the muscles and ligaments and spine and fascia and organs.
When you're under stress.
Stretch the applicability of that evidence by making huge logical leaps based on
the evidence they presented.
Bristol's vibrate at different levels,
depending on their composition and color as to the cells in the human
body.
Excessive pseudoscience, praise, not on the fact that people are dumb,
but that we are completely incapable of knowing every scientific principle that
intersects with our lives. I have a headache. I take a Tylenol,
but I personally have zero idea how the biochemistry involved makes it better
with that in mind,
let's get into the profound lack of context implicit in the idea that it isn't
viruses that cause COVID-19,
but 5g will have to start with the question.
How do we know what viruses cause what illnesses before the 18 hundreds people
had basically no idea what was making most people sick. Sure.
They had some theories,
but it wasn't until the 17 and 18 hundreds that a series of discoveries vastly
expanded our knowledge of the microbial world that was killing us.
You probably remember Louie pastor as the guy that discovered heating up milk
would make sure your cow juice wouldn't murder you,
but his experiments help the formation of the germ theory of disease.
Notably pastor had a rival named Robert Koch who was also looking into the tiny
murderous world around us.
Koch's work in microbiology is the entire reason why we know when you've got,
say the flu instead of COVID and it's Robert Koch who Cowan sites to
support his claims that COVID-19 isn't caused by a virus, cocaine,
his peers were faced with the question,
how exactly does a scientist determine of all the millions of organisms in our
body? Which one is making us sick?
Koch had four simple rules known as Koch's postulates one.
We can suspect a specific microorganism of causing an illness.
If we can find that organism in all the cases of that illness,
but that's not enough because there are many different microorganisms in all of
our bodies, which brings us to two.
You have to be able to isolate this microorganism and grow it in a pure culture.
Let's say you've got someone suffering from COVID-19.
You can take a nasal sample,
filter out the other organisms and grow some disease juice in a Petri dish.
Three, the culture of microbe will cause disease in a healthy host.
Now modern scientists often don't want to intentionally make people sick with
their ethics and all.
So instead they might introduce their disease Jews to some healthy lab cells or
sadly a monkey rat or some other animal.
And see if they develop COVID-19 symptoms for you're able to watch as your newly
infected organism produces enough virus or bacteria for you to once again,
isolated in a Petri dish, making a brand new batch of disease juice,
and in line with making logical leaps from real science,
Cowan uses Koch's postulates as a reason to explain why COVID and the flu are
hoaxes for one, he claims that in Boston, during the Spanish flu,
they suck the snot out of people and injected it into healthy people.
Eliciting no symptoms that would make it disqualified by Koch's third postulate,
except well, we looked at that paper and the author pretty much says,
I'm pretty sure we're doing everything wrong. Ironically,
the whole reason people found the virus that caused the flu was Koch's
postulates unsure of what was causing everyone to get sick with the Spanish flu.
Some suspected a bacteria called Pfeiffer's bacillus while others suspected a
specific virus. Importantly,
bacteria are much larger than viruses so they can be filtered out with tiny
little virus sized holds true to Koch's postulate. In 1918,
two French researchers were able to infect monkeys in a human with their
isolated bacteria, free virus, Jews who subsequently got sick,
thus giving strong evidence that the flu was caused by the influenza virus
instead of Pfeiffer's bacillus. Additionally,
other researchers help rule out Pfeiffer's bacillus because they found it in all
kinds of people without the flu, thus violating Coke's first postulate.
It's important to note how these findings come about because of a community of
scientists and not a lone study or researcher Koch's postulates were not only
critical a hundred years ago. They're critical today.
When researchers in Korea wanted to figure out what was,
what we now call COVID-19.
They isolated a virus that looked a lot like SARS and infected healthy lab cells
to fulfill part of Koch's postulates, that virus, they called SARS cov,
who researchers have also claimed to successfully infect monkeys and rats.
Koch's postulates are not perfect though. And even he realized this,
for instance, some people contract infections, but don't show symptoms.
And while we might want to say, boom, Coke, debunked.
There's plenty of other reasons to believe that microorganisms are still
infectious without effecting everyone who contracts them.
Like when I searched an Irish cook managed to give typhoid to a bunch of the
families she cooked for despite being perfectly healthy or how some viruses can
go dormant in our bodies like herpes before becoming active. Again,
scientists often debate how to best tweak Koch's postulates,
modern techniques like sequencing the genome of a suspected virus and comparing
it to genetically similar viruses like comparing COVID-19 to SARS can provide
evidence for identifying the microbial causes of an illness,
not even Dremel in Coke's time,
but to people like Cowan playing it fast and loose with the scientific
principles they dish out.
We'll say things like Koch's postulates assert that 100% of people with the
virus or bacteria should have symptoms and idea that not even Coke believed.
And of course there's little to no experimental evidence that suggests viruses
are just cell poop.
And I'm unaware of anyone blasting lab cells with 5g waves that was able to
produce the novel coronavirus from nothing like our energy healer.
How points to real research to imply that he's correct.
But here's our favorite part of the story. Cowan is a medical doctor.
He went to medical school.
He should have the medical context for why these claims are completely bonkers,
but it's also worth noting.
Most doctors are not research scientists and their training focuses on rote
memorization, not critical thinking or modern research techniques.
And this is at least part of the reason you can find plenty of people with
medical degrees saying the dumbest things about vaccines or Corona virus.
They think simply being armed with the facts in a vacuum will lead them to the
right conclusion, which brings us to the problem of evidence.
We're never really taught to think critically about evidence and how it should
shape our understanding of the world to figure out why let's consider Cowen's
evidence. First. He claims that 5g was launched in Wu Han China,
where COVID originated aside from the fact that this is just wrong.
As 5g services previously existed in parts of the U S and South Korea.
This is allegedly correlational evidence as,
as a series of pandemics that coincided with radio and other technology.
At this point in the video, countless Lords have likely,
already commented LOL correlation. Doesn't equal causation, and that's true,
but correlation is important evidence,
evidence that we use all the time and the fact that places which have no 5g are
also experiencing COVID outbreaks is evidence that this specific correlation is
bull let's turn back to Cowan slam dunk on how the Boston researchers couldn't
deliberately infect people with the flu, not even with their gross flutes,
not this evidence has meant to cast out on the prevailing idea that viruses are
infectious. If a virus isn't giving people the flu,
then surely something else must be like the radio.
What should we make of all this evidence?
One route is just to call it bad evidence.
No 5g existed elsewhere before Wu Han no correlation doesn't equal
causation, but there's something else going on here that we've seen a lot.
And people like Cowan energy healers and flat earthers,
a fetishization of the crucial experiment.
We could simply get one of these ring, laser gyroscopes.
We would be able to prove once. And for all that,
there is no rotation to the earth.
Crucial experiment was an idea set forth by Francis bacon. Who many of you know,
as the scientific method guy, you've probably heard a story like this.
People have some outdated or wrong idea,
and someone has a Eureka moment designing an experiment to settle the case once.
And for all think Newton with his prism, proving his theory of light,
or if your energy guide,
the double slit experiment is the crucial experiment that proves you can realign
people's energy by snapping.
I I'm making sounds with my hands.
I'm putting energy into the field around some of these body.
Well, science is full of these important experiments.
The problem with crucial experiments is that they rarely if ever exists.
As we understand them.
This all speaks to the basic problem in science known as under determination,
which the Stanford encyclopedia of philosophy defines as the simple idea that
the evidence available to us at a given time may be insufficient to determine
what beliefs we should hold in response to it.
This idea originates from the work of peer doom,
a French physicist who argues that when one performs an experiment and tests a
hypothesis,
there's never one single hypothesis being when one wants to test the idea that
the flu is infectious.
One might cough on a healthy person to see if they get sick,
but there is an innumerable amount of assumptions and hypothesis embedded in any
simple test, for instance, that the flu virus travels via air,
that it's always present in a sick person's lung or throat sick person is always
infectious. That virus has exist. And so on. When an experiment fails,
do them argues. It's impossible to say where the failure lies.
Let's unpack within the context of our Boston flu experiment,
putting someone's snot into someone's body rests on all kinds of hypotheses and
assumptions.
Reading the paper has the author as a good scientist asking questions about what
kind of assumptions he incorrectly made about the flu does transporting said
mucus for four hours somehow harm the flu virus, where the people,
they try to infect already exposed without knowing it.
Do people stop being contagious even while they're sick. Thus,
the conclusion that the flu is not infectious was not even considered by the
performer of the experiment.
All it really shows was how little they knew about the flu and viral infections,
which would hopefully encourage scientists to dig deeper and deeper.
It's also important to remember that science happens.
People build conclusions from evidence, and unfortunately this is a prime way.
Human bias and dumb mastery can enter the scientific process and a complete
ignorance of how human bias easily enters.
The scientific process has led to some of science's worst mishaps.
I want to stress this slam dunk flu evidence from Cowan because this kind of
tactic,
isn't just a common refrain for anti-vaxxers energy healers or the 5g causes
COVID people,
but almost every talking head you've seen on television and YouTube. Seriously,
just look at any video with owns in the title,
and you'll likely find some pundit or straight up quack offering a hand full of
key studies that thoroughly debunked the other side.
But the problem is science doesn't work like this.
Science is not an issue individual process where one scientist performs a
crucial experiment and changes the game it's done with other scientists,
but we pastor and Robert Koch would have been relegated to the dustbin of
history. If their ideas about germs,
weren't built upon by countless experiments and theorization of their peers,
not only peers who replicated their experiments,
but built upon their techniques as they went looking for microbes developed
vaccines and looked for evidence that poked holes in their theories,
even the French researchers who isolated the flu virus would have been long
forgotten. If their evidence wasn't corroborated and built upon an entire way,
web of knowledge is built as historian.
Naomi arrestees writes summarizing [inaudible] work experiments.
Simply tell us if a theory is confirmed or weakened by the facts. Um,
you see someone touting and experiment that seemingly upends,
everything we know, Oh, about one thing or another ask yourself,
does it really many conspiracy theories have a smoking gun like Andrew
Wakefield's discredited study linking autism to the MMR vaccine or Cowan slam
dunk of a study from a hundred years ago,
if pseudoscience is appealing because it latches on to scientific principles
that we vaguely remember from high,
the full context of those principles is what often makes pseudoscience fall
apart. It's the web of knowledge, not individual facts,
studies or tests that makes science robust.
So when Calen points to the very basic principles of virology to disprove the
idea that COVID-19 is an infectious disease,
it's only the context of those principles that can save us. And for scientist,
arrestee says, it's not just on them to tell the world what they know,
but how they know it.
There's the constant refrain and a lot of battle alarmism that we don't know the
effects of this thing.
And while plenty of corporations have put out products that accidentally killed
a bunch of people, the answer is not to invent a cause out of thin 5g Laden air.
Of course,
Thomas Cowen's idea that an untested technology is dangerous to human health and
should be stopped at all.
Costs is also incredibly ironic because his own medical license was put on
probation. After he suggested a patient with breast cancer,
take a drug that has never gone through any safety trials without even
suggesting to the patient. It might be dangerous.
He also did so without ever consulting the patient's medical records or
performing an in-person examination. Whoops,
thanks again to all our patrons for supporting us.
Don't forget to subscribe and we'll catch you next time. Peace.
[Inaudible].